[Music]
on this saturday night holiday concern
over covet 19.
we need everybody if you've turned off
your cobit switch you need to turn it
back on and pay careful attention how
the virus could spoil gatherings on the
first long weekend without restrictions
ukraine's resistance we're fighting for
our very existence for our future as
independent countries in the nation
russia's relentless offensive in the
ruins of medieval and why many nations
are choosing to remain neutral
preparing for a heartbreaking homecoming
i've come to terms with the fact that my
life will never be the same ukrainian
scientists stuck in antarctica are
heading back amid a worsening war and
deadly durban disaster with hundreds
already killed south africa braces for
more flooding as rains restart in the
east
[Music]
global national reporting tonight
mithu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
the first significant holiday weekend
with few restrictions is underway right
as coveted 19's sixth wave sweeps across
canada with so many on the move the
concern is holiday infections will drive
up cases and hospitalizations evidence
suggests there is already accelerated
transmission due to new and highly
infectious omicron sub variants as mike
trolley reports experts are urging
canadians to remain vigilant and be
careful during holiday gatherings
it's official now the coveted paws on
annual traditions is over three years
have passed since many young canadians
joined the hunt for easter eggs gathered
for passover dinner or went to the
mosque for ramadan and you can tell how
much it was missed we feel like there's
been an excessive amount of pent-up
demand for the community to get back
together be involved with one another
and be in person i'll look the other way
it was only a year ago ontario premier
doug ford declared a state of emergency
amidst kovitt's third wave when the
province's health care system was
struggling to keep up
now with most restrictions including
mask mandates lifted canadians are
flipping between caution
as of right now we're still getting
together but we're kind of playing it by
ear
we'll see a couple of family members are
sick so they might be sitting it out and
all out fatigue most people i'm friends
with them like my family and stuff just
haven't really been looking because
they're kind of tired from it that
weariness has health experts worried
they've tracked the growth of the
current sixth wave through a rise in a
manageable number of hospitalizations
but with the omicron subvariant ba2
being far more transmissible the actual
number of cases in the community is
believed to be enormous too many people
have you know once we lifted the
restrictions it's basically kovit's
death well i'm sorry covenant is not
done with us so we need everybody if
you've turned off your covet switch you
need to turn it back on and pay careful
attention
epidemiologists expect covert numbers
will wane through the spring and summer
and are hopeful no new variant emerges
but masks they say are still a smart
move in crowded settings i don't see
the reasoning behind trying to
remove as many protections as we can as
quickly as we can it makes no sense to
me it's an emotional response not a
scientific one was a restriction-free
long weekend the right decision we won't
know that answer for a few weeks mike
drolite global news toronto
it is a massive travel weekend right
across the u.s as well the u.s has
extended its federal mass mandate for
another 15 days until may 3rd requiring
people to wear masks on planes trains
and in transit hubs there are fears a
substantial surge is just around the
corner in new york city health officials
say the two omicron sub variants are
fueling significant community
transmission
20 states including the entire northeast
have seen daily case numbers jump by at
least 30 percent in the last two weeks
after a two-month decline
more cities across china are locking
down as cases explode streets are
completely empty in shanghai china's
largest city suffering a record 3
500 cases in just 24 hours most of
shanghai's 25 million residents remain
under strict lockdown as case counts
accelerate residential buildings are
being converted into quarantined centers
to house the explosion of new infections
under china's covet zero policy everyone
who tests positive must quarantine at a
designated facility
toronto police say five men were injured
overnight in a drive-by shooting that
they called a random act of violence
officers say a suspect opened fire at a
group of muslim men who were gathered in
a parking lot shortly after finishing
midnight prayer service all five were
treated in hospital for injuries
although none are said to be
life-threatening police say the suspect
fled the scene in a blue car but further
details remain unclear
officers stress it's too early to
confirm a motive
now to ukraine where officials are
urging residents of keeve not to return
home today as the capital region comes
under renewed fire from russian forces
the latest attacks come as the un's
human rights commission delivers a grim
update more than 1900 civilians are now
estimated to have died since the war
broke out more than 160 of them children
reggie shakini looks at the latest
russian offensive that's targeting major
cities across the country and a warning
some of the images in this story are
disturbing
this is a grim sign in a city hanging by
a thread
russia claiming it's in control of a
steel plant in mariupol one of the last
remaining outposts of the ukrainian
forces in that city an attack on a
makeshift military installation that
resulted in civilian loss russians have
shown that they are willing to use
anything and everything to try and
subjugate our country russia now claims
it's cleared all ukrainian troops from
mariupol and if so it would mark a first
victory if confirmed kiev says that
would end talks with moscow
but the military push still continues
across besieged luhansk
while shelling proved deadly in harkev
hitting an administrative building
the blast wave partially damaged nearby
buildings including an apartment this
official says
moscow has threatened to increase its
attacks possible retaliation for the
sinking of a warship the kremlin claims
was due to a fire
in la vie the easter end passover
weekend brought new threats where its
reported russian missiles were taken out
by the country's air defense system for
us there is no question here we're
fighting for our very existence for our
future
fighting that's earned soldiers the
respect of their president who awarded
the medals on saturday for bravery in
the past
against the agony of the present
we put a photo of him there he was
always smiling says this mother whose
son died fighting for ukraine
she's afraid russia will return and
destroyed this graveyard in tortillanest
one dotted with landmines
unthinkable atrocities are now an
everyday thought with more than 900
civilians already recovered from mass
graves around kiev
now under the threat of a more intense
fight in the east lies the evergreen
request for more weapons from the west
hundreds of millions of dollars worth
are being sent this weekend but
officials in the united states fear that
could be expended within days of arrival
regiskini global news washington
canada pledged this week to send up to
150 troops to neighboring poland in an
effort to ramp up humanitarian support
for the millions of ukrainians fleeing
the war some 100 armed forces members
are already on their way but this week
on the west block mercedes-stevenson
looks at the growing calls for ottawa
and other western nations to do more
mercedes
nethu the apparent war crimes the world
is bearing witness to in ukraine have a
haunting familiarity for retired
lieutenant general romeo de lair who was
in command of the u.n mission in rwanda
during the genocide in that country
general delaire does not mince his words
on the west's failure to act more
decisively in ukraine the west has
learned absolutely nothing delayer says
it is unclear whether what is happening
right now is in fact genocide in ukraine
that would mean that it's directed by
the russian state or whether the
atrocities are being committed by rogue
russian commanders but he believes that
determining the answer to that is vital
and says that investigators must get on
the ground in ukraine as soon as
possible to figure that out
delaire believes the west has a moral
obligation to act in support of ukraine
and says it will be judged by its
failures the international community
signed up that if there is a genocide we
all have a responsibility to stop it to
stop it which means to engage in
stopping it not watching it and not
letting it treat you know hundreds of
thousands like i witnessed in rwanda
with nobody coming but in fact to stop
it
this week on the west block i'll also
speak with defense minister anita anand
about what more the canadian government
can and will be doing to help ukraine
global news has learned that ottawa is
looking at sending canadian army armored
vehicles to ukraine that could include
things like tanks lavs and coyotes
minister anand did not deny that her
government is looking at dipping into
the canadian military stocks to help
ukraine i have nothing to announce at
this time but i will say that we are
taking an all hands on deck approach to
ensure that we are responding
effectively to
the items that minister resnickoff my
counterpart in ukraine has indicated
ukraine needed military sources say they
are concerned that donating canadian
equipment will deplete the limited
inventory in the canadian armed forces
and that donating that equipment also
comes with significant complications
because the ukrainian military is not
trained on how to maintain or use those
specific types of armored vehicles
the military sources say they worry that
those vehicles could be of limited value
if they break down quickly after
arriving nithu
mercedes stephenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes and you can catch the full
interviews with romeo delaire and anita
anand tomorrow on the west block right
here on global
since the start of the war western
leaders have been quick to condemn
russia's invasion but many others have
stayed neutral or muted with some even
blaming the west for what's happening
president zielenski is reportedly
working to court some of those countries
as he looks to speak to members of the
african union in the coming days more
than half of them either voted against
or abstained from a recent u.n vote to
suspend russia from the human rights
council redmond shannon looks at what
lies behind those decisions
the horrors of the war in ukraine are
undeniable and often unimaginable at
least to people consuming media outside
of russia last week's united nations
resolution successfully kicked russia
out of the un human rights council but
it was far from unanimous 93 mostly
western or richer nations supported the
resolution 24 voted against and 76
either weren't present to vote or
abstained
among them south africa its president
has laid some blame with nato that its
eastward expansion
would lead to greater
not less
instability in the region the world
order can sometimes look different
depending on perspective there are many
countries that are very dependent on
russia that have privately told us told
me very directly
we agree with you
but there are limits on what we can say
and do the nato-led campaigns in
afghanistan and libya have led to calls
of hypocrisy from many developing
nations one of baptism
is all over the place here
and it includes
the israel-palestine issue
the issues and
other interventions countries like
nigeria have signed arms deals with
russia after being shunned by the west
over human rights concerns
india too relies on russian arms we are
for dialogue and diplomacy
we are for urgent cessation of violence
delhi resisting western pressure to take
sides the support given by the soviet
union and then russia
in the security council on the kashmir
issue for india has been very pivotal
the position of russia's ally china
perhaps a factor for african nations
that rely on it for investment to see
russia on part of many countries
as representing anti-colonialism
there is a conflation of anti-colonial
with anti-westernism but russia's
critics argue this invasion is simply
part of a push to re-establish its
colonial conquests redmond shannon
global news
london up thousands remain evacuated as
early season wildfires break out across
the u.s
[Music]
it may be just spring but parts of the
u.s are already seeing their fair share
of wildfires in northern colorado some
residents have been evacuated as
firefighters combat this fire that
started friday progress is being made to
contain it but in new mexico the ongoing
mcbride fire has already killed at least
two people since it began earlier this
week that blaze has burned down more
than 200 buildings and has forced
thousands to flee their homes
emergency services in parts of south
africa remain on high alert as more rain
and damaging winds are expected in the
country's flood-ravaged eastern region
torrential downpours left a trail of
death and destruction around the port
city of durban earlier this week nearly
400 deaths have been reported dozens
remain missing and tens of thousands
have been left homeless officials aren't
expecting nearly as much rain in the
coming days but warn more flooding could
come as the situation worsens on the
ground
three chinese astronauts are back on
solid ground after spending six months
aboard the country's newest space
station the crew landed back on earth
today in the gobi desert in the northern
region of inner mongolia nine hours
after beginning their descent the
mission is the longest ever for china
which is excluded from being part of the
international space station over u.s
fears about china's space program being
run by the communist party's military
wing
coming up the stranded scientists
setting sail from a remote research base
to their war-torn homes in ukraine
as russia's assault on their homeland
drags on ukrainians around the world
have had to watch the invasion with
feelings of horror and helplessness now
imagine going through that while
stranded in one of the loneliest places
on earth that is exactly what happened
to a group of ukrainian scientists they
have been stuck at this remote research
base on an antarctic island thousands of
kilometers from home
jackson proskow looks at their struggle
away from home and their bitter task of
returning to a country that has been
changed forever
perched on the edge of antarctica sits a
tiny ukrainian outpost
this is the vernatsky research center
where penguins frolic among the ice
flows
and where a small team of ukrainian
scientists has been trapped helplessly
watching the invasion of their country
14 000 kilometers away information about
missile strikes and other cities shocked
all of us
it's impossible to describe the feeling
of heartlessness in this situation each
of us spent the first week of the world
without sleep the researchers were
supposed to end their year-long
expedition in february but war left them
frozen in place at the bottom of the
world
their only link to home has been
satellite internet it's slow and often
stops working
what they do know is their villages and
cities are being bombed their families
and friends are in danger we all felt
the mix of emotions like anger
despair
helplessness
frustration at a time like this the
scientists would all rather be back in
ukraine
as the situation has grown more dire
they've turned from research to outreach
on youtube the team appealed to their
fellow russian scientists to speak out
against the invasion and they unfurled
the blue and yellow flag of ukraine in
the snow with a message of solidarity
our hearts are full of pain from what is
happening in our homeland
isolation and desperation have taken a
physical toll according to the
expedition's doctor we were quite
stressed and anxious it led
to the blood pressure spikes
and insomnia
relief finally came this week when a
replacement team arrived along with a
ship to take the scientists home
they still don't know how long the
journey will take or what awaits them
i've come to terms with the fact that my
life will never be the same
it seems
that the war will be not ended quickly
after war followed them to the most
isolated place on the planet they know
the ukraine they return to will be
vastly different from the country they
left more than a year ago
jackson proskow global news
coming up how traditional easter egg art
is taking on special meaning for
ukrainians in alberta
events this weekend will likely involve
a longtime tradition for many ukrainian
canadians those vibrant hand-painted
easter eggs but ukrainians who have fled
war are still struggling and will be too
far from the comforts of home to
celebrate that's why a calgary artist is
using the long time holiday tradition to
support those coming into alberta and
she's hoping her prayers for peace can
help here's gil tucker
these are ukrainian easter eggs or what
we call piss and kit and their symbolism
of life
and rebirth a tradition that goes back
centuries we don't paint we use wax and
dye veteran artist dana diduck sharing
her talents with the crowds here at the
calgary farmers market every line every
symbol has a meaning we've got the
ukrainian flag we do the tree of life as
well they're works of art just
unbelievable the threshold or the
trident that's the national symbol of
ukraine and this easter those symbols
are more important than ever we're doing
prayers for ukraine for peace send our
love to ukraine dana is also working to
welcome people fleeing the fighting
right now we're doing a ton of
fundraisers one of them is at this mall
it's called pisanki for peace dana and
other artists are auctioning off their
work online raising money to support
ukrainians coming to alberta getting a
bit of help from some kids they put
their hands there letting them know that
they can do something to raise awareness
for what is going on and also support a
ukrainian families and help other kids
it's fantastic that
artisans are are getting together and
using their craft
to try and help the people of ukraine
dana was in ukraine three years ago my
heritage is ukrainian my blood's
ukrainian developing her skills
alongside artists there one of which is
actually fighting in the war other
essence artists that we know in ukraine
right now they're weaving the camouflage
net for the fighters
and doing everything that they can to
help while dana does her part here the
stag for zielinski for strength symbols
on a small scale out to make a big
difference put in our love and put on
our prayers bill tucker global news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm nitu garcia we'll
leave you with another artist's tribute
to ukrainians toronto artist maria amiri
painted this mural featuring a child
with a ukrainian flag while holding a
very fitting message amiri says it's
because children represent purity and
have no hate or greed in them there's
another much larger section to the piece
with a more vulgar message aimed at
vladimir putin here's a hint it involves
the f word
thanks for watching i'll see you back
here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]